this is how we're getting to the Moon  NASA's SLS lifts the Orion spacecraft  carrying astronauts Orion meets up with  a lunar variant of Starship in lunar  orbit the crew transfers to Starship  which takes them to the surface of the  Moon  for the trip home Starship lifts off  meets up with Orion which was left in  lunar orbit the crew transfers over to  Ryan and returns to earth  but what if starship were used to go all  the way from the Earth to the Moon  Starship could launch meet up with  another Starship to refuel before  journeying to the moon this version of  Starship looks a little different it's  not the lunar variant it requires the  heat shield and flaps for landing back  on Earth